et en tunisie également de nouvelles
restrictions mises en place à partir
d'aujourd'hui pour faire face à
l'augmentation des contaminations les
conditions d'accès au territoire sont
désormais renforcées ont fait le point
avec notre correspondant sur place bat
sam shemie
refus des voyageurs non vaccinés
réduction de la durée de validité des
tests pcr la tunisie jo si les
formalités d'accès à son territoire face
à l'évolution de la pandémie de
coronavirus marquée par l'émergence du
variant au micron l'indulgence accordée
aux voyageurs non vaccinés prendra fin
dès le 1er décembre prochain à cette
date toute personne souhaitant se rendre
en tunisie devra présenter son pass
vaccinale accompagné d'un test pcr de
moins de 48 heures contre 72 heures
auparavant une nouvelle vague qui
inquiète la communauté internationale
alors que de plus en plus de pays ont
d'ores et déjà pris des dispositions
drastiques à l'image du maroc ou encore
du japon qui ont totalement fermé leurs
frontières terrestres et aériennes
même si la tunisie est pour le moment
épargné par une recrudescence des cas
est la commission scientifique de lutte
contre la propagation du commis 19 a
appelé à la vigilance et à plus de
prudence selon le dernier bilan publié
lundi soir par le ministère de la santé
trois décès ont été recensés à la même
date pourtant le billère le bilan à
25000 365 morts dus coronavirus depuis
l'apparition de la pandémie malgré un
taux de positivité stable de 3 63% la
tunisie compte généraliser une troisième
dose de vaccin anti qu'ovide pour les
plus de 18 ans en prévision d'une
éventuelle est cinquième vague alors que
le pays a dépassé la barre symbolique
des 10 millions de personnes ayant reçu
au moins une dose de vaccin le
gouvernement poursuit sa campagne
d'appel aux dons étrangers pour se
prémunir en cas d'une nouvelle vague
épidémiologique